youtube and little did you know there
would be like millions of people
that would want to talk to you basically
about it yeah
that's that's basically the how it is
uh and yeah okay it wasn't really like
that from the start you know
uh when i was starting out there were
only a few views
uh only i think after the channel
reached like maybe 1 000 subscribers
where people were
really getting into it and then i i
guess all it took
was one viral video uh of of a certain
bobby fischer game and then
really a lot of people started pouring
in
i didn't realize that it was one video
there's a bobby fischer game
yeah yeah that's interesting yeah okay
let me just uh since i'm using my two
monitors one for the
one for our conversation one for the
board i need another one
so it's gonna be my phone to actually
see if my live stream is operational
all right let's check okay yeah it seems
to be working there are some people
watching
all right there we go it honestly looks
like you're
going to the side to write down chess
moves it's like the points of our
conversation you're like okay e4
v3
all right just a few more seconds and i
think that's it all right yeah i got it
all right now at least uh i i will be
able to read
some of the chat cool
because i i haven't uh had like i know
everyone is streaming uh
like with guests and everything but so
far i've never tried it
it's sort of a pain in the back yeah
someone's saying there's a lag in a gad
stream
uh and i'm not exactly sure what to do
i i always get a lag on my guest's
screen
uh yeah i'm not sure yeah i don't know
what the hell to do about it to be
honest
um
yeah yeah i don't know i'm sure there is
okay let me just check
uh on my stream okay uh hello everyone
uh i'm
kind of using three monitors here so i'm
just
trying to set everything up is there
some sort of a lag or anything
uh on either of our streams
okay oh that's that's okay
no the people no the people on my stream
say that everything is fine both of our
our audios are fine
yeah and also uh what what are they what
do people usually refer to you as
like are you niles or or do people
actually call you kashmir or
um most of my friends call me niles
[Music]
yeah and what what should i call you
actually
ah whatever tony antonio tony
whatever is easier to pronounce is fine
cool my best friend's name is actually
anthony
so yeah sometimes we call him tuan
tuan like like antoine like antoine yeah
we have a bunch of names
um but yeah we have a lot of jokes also
because he's like the bug he's like the
ants so we have uh
we have little you know things up on the
we at first birthday we've given him
like ant cakes and things like that
would be like a little ant
uh ants marching along things like that
yeah
stupid yes that's how did you
how did you come up with a gad mater or
is it a god medora
i never really knew no it's actually i
got matter but
i will not uh say it as uh i made a
separate video on it so it's
it takes really long to explain it and
it's just uh you know a mouthful okay
whatever
it is what it is yeah yeah it's a it's
it's something not to be
not to ever be translated you know it's
it's a word
yeah okay i believe you it's not meant
to be translated
it's like a voldemort or something yeah
yeah
only nothing happens when you say it
okay
um all right so should we do some should
we do some chess
yeah yeah that's what we're here for
yeah i just remembered
how you are there any live shows now
during the pandemic i mean i imagine no
uh not really man not really to be
honest
um there is i just had one that was
basically a parking lot and people drove
in
and and they have a little space outside
of their cars that they could dance
around in
and i dj'd and it was it was good
i mean from from going from no shows to
that that was actually pretty nice
but in terms of you know the festival
setting where there's just a huge crowd
of people
it wasn't the same as that it was it was
different yeah it's definitely different
do you see humanity going back you know
to such
large gatherings where people you know
are crowded and everyone's sweaty and
you know
people are drinking and having good fun
yeah
i think so i think probably towards the
end of the year
i mean some countries are
doing this flip-flop sort of thing where
they have progress
and then they say okay we're going to go
out we're going to you know go to
restaurants and then
their numbers go up so yeah it's hard to
say how are things in croatia
i would say much better than in in most
places
yeah some cities are not doing all that
great but most are
like we don't have like pretty much
everything is allowed here
like uh even bars are open you can go to
a bar
not indoors you have to be outside but
you know
if the bars are open i guess everything
is you know
almost fully operational libraries also
you know they're working so
yeah same and same in the u.s i would
say it's it's
outside seating but every time you say
outside some people just push
closer together they just yeah yeah push
push push push
so yeah it's hard to say but i just got
the vaccine um
and i was a little under the weather but
i'm okay
now yeah so like for like what two three
days maybe
yeah even just a day honestly it was
mostly just yesterday i was sort of
tired
and now i'm okay pretty much
you do have to take like another one is
it a two-part
yeah that was the second part so the
first part was no problem
i felt sore in my arm but no problem and
then the second one
i felt under the weather some people get
really sick from the second one
uh but no not too bad honestly i'm
here i am with you i'm i wasn't gonna i
wasn't gonna miss this
yeah okay yeah uh so what uh
what kind of uh what's your time format
what do you most
enjoy uh i like like 10
15 minutes with increments because i'm
just kind of a slower player honestly
okay so a slow game uh with with with
some nice conversation that's
uh that's the good stuff yes and we can
either play against each other or we can
do hand in brain
uh against other people all right
i'm guessing hand and brain is also what
people enjoy nowadays uh
we can start with that uh but
you can start any game you want and just
send me the link and i'm gonna
follow it here okay um
so uh i'm not how do i send you the link
um oh here you know just uh create a
game and then
whatever it says in the browser just
copy paste that like to twitter or
wherever you want
okay yeah i think twitter should work
nicely
okay um so
at one point i saw all the different
invitations that i was getting
uh but i'm not sure where they went
um open challenges
if somebody wants to invite me if you're
on the stream i'm niles dar
it's just n-i-l-e-s-d-h-a-r
um okay actually i i
i very rarely uh uh stream on chess.com
or
rather never so i don't even know how to
add you
uh that's why that's why we're going to
hand them brain
uh so i i don't have to add you for the
moment
okay cool sounds good so somebody just
somebody just invited me so i think i
can copy you this link now
and there it is i just put it in what
all right um
yeah i got it i got it let me just grab
that
he just did e4
want me to just pawn or what do you
think
no no wait i i still have to open it
right or we're losing time no it's okay
what's the time format it's 15 with
increment actually it hasn't started yet
it doesn't start i mean that's that's
way way
too much time so we'll be fine that's
too much time yeah
yeah we'll be fine no worries uh let me
just
let me just shoot my auto abort though
okay i'm just gonna do a pawn because it
wants to abort me if i don't make a move
so yeah okay let's uh let's do pawn
okay okay sorry
it's okay yeah i've never i've never
done this dual
dual streaming stuff so it's taking me a
while but we'll get there
no worries it's cool you deny f3
just that okay that's what i would play
even if i was playing so
you know if you want to sacrifice
something that's also fine
okay i he did knight f3 so
i'll just just do knight
i'll just you with me he didn't i he's
white sorry
yeah let me just uh still not completely
there
okay i just need to to grab this one
all right let me just grab that
all right there we go yeah
uh that's your that's you uh
yeah that's the opponent yeah okay now
we're here now we're checking it out
all right i think there's actually some
sort of a way to follow you
um so i can you know if you if you play
a another game
we can just do that oh so this one isn't
working
no no it's working i just want to add
you as friend
and maybe there's some sort of a follow
yeah there's a follow option
you are now following and also report
we're going to report you for
two strong moves uh all right
all right so who is the uh brain here
and uh
who who is the head i think i think you
should be the brain
uh because that's how it's been going
okay and you you're operating the mouse
for the moment
okay at the moment yeah and we're black
yeah
uh yeah we're black and we have a pretty
standard
opening here okay what's the time okay
okay now now we're now we're doing well
all right let's go
let's go bishop bishop okay
yeah that's the stuff always on this
diagonal
okay let's go let's go king
okay easy enough
we're in this okay how did you know i
wanted the castle
nowadays everything is popular king f8
also very popular
yeah king seven yeah
all right okay we got him thinking okay
let's
okay okay this is very nice uh
well uh do we wanna do we wanna play
something interesting
of course yeah i mean that's why we're
here yeah all right we're gonna we're
gonna go for pawn
okay
simple kick away i figured was what you
i thought i thought you would go for g6
instead of h6
g6 yeah yeah uh
i don't know g6 how that and benefits
but all right no i meant because of your
song
oh okay
the jokes are coming out the jokes are
coming out all right
okay let's go let's go with the pawn
okay
um
wow just i don't want to open up the
king side too much so i think i'm just
going to
start the fiance all right
i could either do that or i could ah or
i could do d6
i think which i like more like there
there is no wrong pawn move
okay okay
very very well uh let's go for pawn
go for pawn um
okay um i don't know if i see it
okay um this seems to
[Music]
equals mc squared yes that's the stuff
what did you play
oh you played that okay this is going to
be fun
all right i'm i'ma say captures even
before he makes a move
oh sorry i should i now i see what the
little
tactic is here oh but okay he he's
thinking that's
that's that's great we got him where we
want him
okay all right pawn
okay if if we survive this uh we're
gonna
have to go for a beer there there's no
other way
[Laughter]
sorry man i uh still still warming up
no problem we're not here to win we're
here to
uh to enjoy all right let's go bishop
okay
which yeah better i am reading the
comments a little bit but i have to do
it on my phone since i'm using
i have to use two monitors for a stream
like this
and i still haven't implemented the
third one
so i am reading them a little bit
all right what do we have here
but do you just play the bishop there
very nice very nice yeah all right
let's do let's do night let's do night
there's only one so that's why i chose
the knight
okay i think
very very very good okay
all right and we're wow why do we have
so uh so little time
it's because we wasted a lot of time
yeah in the beginning yeah
all right captures obviously but uh
let's do
uh if we do this
we're not gonna have a lot of fun
let's do let's do pawn let's do pawn
really okay yeah let's do pawn
that's a surprise to me we kind of
limited
our bishops yes we did but
we have to try something
but the you know this is only the first
game so all right
we expected that obviously king
okay
yelena is in the chat
all right let's see how he how he
destroys us
all right he's giving us a little hope i
like that he wants to trap our bishop so
he does yeah
in order for the bishop not to get
trapped i'm gonna say
bishop oh sorry pawn pawn
okay
yeah that's a long white bar that is a
long white bar
dude i'm sorry man i i let that was uh
that was just a bad move early on
no but that that's the point in these
hand and brain games
all right what do we have okay bishop
obviously
uh you can turn it off how do you turn
it off i'm sorry i
uh let me just check if i can turn it
off
um
sorry play
huh
okay let me just check um could be blind
but
uh animation type new
okay does anyone know how to turn this
uh the evaluation bar off
and so kashmir can see it uh he's the
one that's playing
so yeah i can't see it yeah so i mean
it's cool and i'm just you know
talking nonsense moves but yeah if
anyone knows how to turn it off
do share uh all right so
we're kind of in a little bit of a
trouble here but not
a lot let's i mean we have to
hmm let's go
yeah let's go let's go bishop
okay
ah top right above the slider all right
uh oh that was stupid dude
sorry oh my god sorry
i'm sorry dude i'm sorry we should
restart this game
oh you played the dead bishop no dude
i'm i was distracted dude we should just
restart this game i should just resign
no okay uh you you think we we can't win
it
no i don't think i don't think we can
win this i should just resign
yeah i was distracted then honestly i
was getting text messages and just
um yeah i don't think so i think we just
resigned this and started a new one
yeah okay uh there's a
yeah i can turn the engine off but not
the evaluation bar it would seem
let me just figure it out okay nope not
here nope that's not it
okay so i i think if you just uh start
another game uh
my interface will update okay
um
yeah do you what what format you think
we should do
ah yeah okay thanks guys i got it
evaluation off
nice oh yeah there's actually a toggle
button for the evaluation to get uh to
get away
all right thanks for that uh sorry
kashmir uh
or niall sorry cash that's fine yeah
uh oh
yeah okay try starting another game and
then we'll see if uh my interface just
auto updates or i have to you know go
for another link
okay um
i'm not sure somebody just sent me the
invite last time so hopefully we'll just
do that again
yeah i think uh i think whenever you
start like a game that
my interface will will auto update but
we'll see
we're still learning you know yeah
okay i just accepted another 1510
all right i think there are there aren't
all that many 15 10
uh challenges i think if you if you
wanted to
like really get a game like five plus
zero would be the way to go
okay is this too much time i just
accepted one should i just accept a
different one
no i don't know that it's fine yeah
anytime format is fine
okay all right we're with the white
pieces now okay i just want to see if it
auto updates
are you already in the game uh
yes i'm in a game yeah okay so it
doesn't auto update let me just uh go to
your
profile and see if i can like follow
your game or something
um yeah it says no game
yeah it says no games in progress are
you sure you're playing good game
uh maybe because i haven't started the
move okay
try to try try to start a move okay
okay pawn pawn yeah
so you've uh started yes i did
and yeah still says no games in progress
this is
really really weird
yeah i'm i'm i'm following you and
everything
should be working but it's not
okay weird um yeah
can i just when i give you that link
before did that work
yeah yeah that worked but i mean it it's
not very smooth if
i have to like update a link every game
yeah i think my camera is mirrored guys
sorry about that but
it's only for this stream so yeah no
worries
yeah but uh i've read that that if you
mirror your camera that
you will look completely different
because you know even though
like we we'd like to think we're
proportional we're
actually not so
everyone looks super weird if you mirror
them
yeah it does look weird to me seeing
myself mirrored
um game aborted damn it
[Music]
uh yeah we just we're waiting too long
um
oh wait you can uh okay i can send you a
message like this hello
okay did you get my message now on
chess.com
um jeez
uh
oh so many things are popping up i'm not
seeing a message
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
would it be in my home okay i see that
i see a message yeah hello all right
cool
yeah okay you can just just paste me the
the link
there okay yeah just pay for the link
there
and uh i'll add you as you can after the
game starts
sorry guys this is uh i'm not usually on
chess.com
so this is very weird to me and uh
niles is uh more accustomed to this so
we thought it'd be smoother
but it's not yeah i know i'm i'm
i'm really not either so maybe we do
like a 10 minute rated
yeah we'll do 10 then five then three
then one then you know
okay so i'm going to paste you the link
on messages there the smiley pillow was
the thing that got your attention
yeah okay just paste it here and
i'm guessing it will pop out
somewhere yeah right oh my god where's
live
i'm live right i'm boarded dude i suck
at this
uh if i leave see the thing is if i go
into messages on here
then it uh then
someone sorry someone someone said that
the bar on the top left is where you
watch your friends games
uh but which bar bar
on the top left there is nothing on the
top left
oh you can actually do that sorry
someone said that
yeah i'll be right back i'm going to get
something to drink yeah i can do leeches
too
man like i can i can i can try to figure
it out
but maybe it'll take longer no it'll
take you too long because then you have
to
set up your interface but for this uh
one stream i i think we'll be able to
to do it cool
why are my videos not sixteen nine uh
everyone's videos are 69 i thought that
it'd just be you know
a little bit easier
aha play live chess than in the chat
type follow niles
okay grab one of those uh energy drinks
thank you man live chess
and then in the chat which chat is that
exactly
oh here like this
okay i'm now following him
okay uh it seems that i'm now following
you now try to start a game
okay cool give me one sec i'm just gonna
play some music in the background
yeah i uh man i'm so bad at promoting
myself but i
my album just came out and the music
video the first music video from the
album just came out
today so that's pretty exciting yeah
yeah i've seen it
uh a few few hours ago yeah a few hours
ago it's uh
very very very beautiful uh like
animations uh oh thank you man it's not
like uh like it's unlike
anything like that's currently uh
available so i did enjoy that
wow thank you so much that's a big
compliment man
yeah i don't know it's a really a
different style to
to animating i don't know i i i don't
know how to express
myself to uh you know
to to really put it but uh it is
it is kind of weird and i i enjoyed that
cool man um yeah maybe at some point i
can play it through and get your
reaction we'll do like an a-gad reaction
video
uh in the middle of this yeah uh sure
thing
i don't know if you okay on twitch
you're actually allowed to do it but if
i do it on on youtube i'll probably get
a copy strike
right yeah i think i should be
whitelisted because it's my own
content i know that you got like racism
charges right because
you're saying white is better yeah yeah
so now
i'm pretty sure they'll be very very
careful before giving me a strike for
anything
that was really silly yeah okay um
all right so 10 minute rated all right
it started wow nice thank you good
people of the chat
for for recommending this oh yeah
there's so many notifications now coming
up i gotta close these
um uh we are with the white pieces so
yeah give me a move
all right let's go pawn i'm pretty sure
we can just spawn
on our way to victory okay just pawn
moves
someone asks the uh have you ever
performed in split
in croatia um
i think it's all been zercha beach
honestly
yeah i think so okay so
uh okay we're gonna we're gonna do
do do a morphe this game let's go pawn
okay i don't know if that means being
kiddo or just take control of the center
i don't know w whatever is uh whatever
is good
okay for for some reason uh let me just
fix this for some reason my interface
went away i don't know if i did that but
i will just fix it okay we're gonna go
with that pawn that's nice
that's the stuff all right let's go
night
all right let me just fix that wow this
is really weird i don't know
what this is all about
there we go that should do it
all right uh let's go bishop
all right yeah focus i was trying to go
for the king's gambit but niles is not
not a fan obviously
uh all right there's nothing really
happening
here so let's go knight
you are muted no sound who is muted i i
think maybe your
your speakers are off man mine
no no no someone says in the chat then
there's no sound i'm pretty sure there's
sound
all right well
let's go ah let's go pawn
yeah okay it's fine nobody's muted uh
yeah if i could if i could put my phone
like here or rather i can't put my phone
here i actually have a phone holder
but it's so clumsy like i could
put it like like over here it'd be nice
or it'd be better here
there are so many things to to fix prior
to streaming
it's crazy okay so we're doing well
uh although we're low on time but we are
up on
raiding i think this is
forest he took with the bishop
yeah pawn obviously yeah
and whatever he does we're gonna castle
okay
thank you mr lee shepherd
okay all right we said anything he does
so we have to
we have to stick with it yeah even
though it's maybe not the greatest but
all right so we know what he's going to
do so we're going to go
night
we're going to go night yeah
um
i'm trying to think which knight move we
like um
[Music]
it's kind of an awkward square if i go
up there with the knight um
i chose knight because we only have one
okay i'm just gonna go with the safe
night option ah
seems so passive to go back with the
night so
never go back while streaming okay
that's like a rule okay
um all right
i yeah
[Music]
nowhere is that we we still have seven
minutes i mean it's it's perfectly fine
okay that's very very interesting
all right if he does what we're hoping
he does
uh then i think it's uh
it's all us for the rest of the game
kamikaze knight all right so he's uh
trying to pose some problems for us here
yeah uh i'm gonna go with i'm gonna go
with pawn
all right that's that's the stuff
hmm all right and then now
now we play something good
yeah let's switch it up play something
good
all right let's play bishop okay
i actually thought maybe you're gonna go
bishop to a3 to make it like really
really crazy
uh but this will this will do nicely
uh if i don't dance we're gonna lose i i
don't think so
all right oh he wants the he wants to go
what is that wow
okay let's uh let's do let's do
night
focus hard for this one
yeah okay for those of you who maybe
don't know what we're doing we're we're
sort of trying uh
to do like a hand and brain thing where
niles is
the the the hand and i'm the brain uh
and we're getting we're getting
destroyed here but you know it's
it's still early still early it's still
early on this one i think
yeah then the night move i okay
i only see one good move for the night
yeah not
the one i was hoping for but
what was the one you were hoping for
capturing the pawn in front of the king
of course
all right uh now we go uh now we go
now we go now we go bishop
oh now i see the tactic i'm sorry man
yeah i see the tactic down oh yeah
that's the fun of hand and brain we're
still gonna grab that knight
it's not a problem yeah
yeah and if we can get the dark square
bishop into the game somehow quickly
it's also gonna be also to be pretty
good
someone is asking were you were you
hiding in the back of the bus
in the yamus song in the in the jammu
song yeah i was in the back of the bus
yeah it's funny we shot this music video
and really the bus isn't even moving
around
it was just the guys shaking it from
side to side
oh how many guys were shaking the bus
we had like eight guys drinking it
inside guys okay
sometimes i was one of the guys all
right so uh
what would you play here pause the video
pause the video yeah take a moment
congratulations
yeah uh we're gonna go with the bishop
yeah
i think we're gonna go yeah i mean we
could
we could either do bishop or we could do
we could do f3 with the queen
yeah yeah what
i won yeah because he loses the queen
with
check yeah that's uh that's the game
yeah
okay so he resigned all right so what's
up
all right we're back in the game
all right that was uh that was a fairly
quick one
yeah we use the gaming check right
all right so if you want we can do
another another 10 or
if we if you want we can try even lower
yeah let's um i think 10 like dude i do
really bad with time
with time uh constraints okay no
no worries okay let's let's see this
other one we're with the black pieces
now
all right i'm like not seeing basic
tactics i don't know
maybe it's this uh vaccine i got man
yeah it's probably
it cures covet but blocks vision
yeah my chest was ruined
that's a side effect they didn't
anticipate all right so
just so we're clear where we are playing
very aggressive yeah
yeah okay okay no no going back with
pieces
okay all right so let's go let's go pawn
meadow is meadow is enjoying himself uh
i think yeah right behind me
uh can't you see him yeah there he is
like a big
big pile of fur yes i see him back there
unfortunately you're cropped on my
screen
so ah okay uh all right let's go
more pawn more fun
um like we can do pawns exclusively here
okay um i'm not
really familiar with this opening so i'm
just gonna do some like
kind of passive stuff no that's that's
the the
the top move recommended by the engine
okay
i'm getting all the greatest hits like
if there was a
egg doll that you pulled the string on
and it would say
this is the top move and it was that
move 49
man okay all right let's do let's do
knight
night knight to go before bishops okay
our friend knows that and that's why
he's playing uh
in such a principled manner let's see
uh all right
all right anything he does on the next
move we're gonna go bishop
i'm pretty sure pretty sure yeah
yeah we are
still going bishop okay
hey i am looking at the chat what's in
the chat sorry i i'm half
i'm using my smartphone to actually you
know read the chat because my two
monitors are needed
for when when you're doing dual streams
i'm gonna have to get a third monitor
but
you know after i move
i think maybe just
this bishop is annoying yeah yeah
aggressive that's
that's great we just have to play
aggressive and that's that's it
we're playing aggressive
all right um yeah i mean we can do we
can do a lot of stuff but we're gonna go
queen
no i'm not watching bullet championship
today it's
too late for me very very gonna be very
tired later
uh let's go cat castles or rat or king
do
you think king or castles i think you're
supposed to say king and then yeah
yeah yeah is it open for me to interpret
all right this i think this is our best
game so far
okay not not even kidding yeah i mean
we're doing so great
great i mean everything is all right so
let's go
let's go pawn let's go pawn
okay um
yes yes they stay hydrated everyone good
good advice from the chat
okay pretty good pawn i guess
i'm trying to see what threats there are
okay that's a that's a good pawn move
okay we can't really play f5 f5 the r9
is in the way of f5
all right yeah uh again for for those of
you who maybe don't know
this hand and brain we're actually not
playing against each other
right
all right uh we're gonna go for for
another pawn
okay
another pawn
i'm just going to be safe here this
seems like a reasonable pawn move
all right very very very reasonable
all right we're gonna we're gonna get to
the pawn i wanted eventually
[Laughter]
this is this is fine
you want to give me a hint about which
point you're thinking of
no it's not the the one of the two that
you've tried
okay how long did i spend
uh designing the april's fools game i
actually
uh didn't i i went uh to take meadow for
a walk and
uh got the idea to use max deutsch and
that's it i just started up the camera
and you know whatever came to my mind i
said it uh you know
the the result maybe was a bit too much
but
it is as it is let's go pawn
okay man at this point i feel like
this has got to be one of the pawn moves
you were considering
let me see here um
am i a quick learner well not as quick
as max deutsch that's for sure
oh that's uh that's a fine fine move
that's a fighter oh okay
all right you have to strike strike the
center
at one right that's what we're doing
see for me i'm always second guessing so
things that are aggressive i tend to shy
away from
but after moving two pawns you didn't
like i figured something aggressive
must be what you're looking for yeah
but it's uh i mean it's so weird i mean
if you look at old chess
books they will tell you ah a6 it's a
waste of time but
nowadays you will see like maybe a super
engine like alpha zero or leela
just zero and they will say ah yes a6 is
the greatest move
so you know maybe what was considered a
waste of time like
30 years ago is the strongest move today
so
who who who who can tell yeah yeah
all right we're gonna we're gonna play
queen
all right that was a fine capture that
was a finding thank you thank you
we're in business here we're in business
yeah
i'd really i wanna i wanna be under your
wing and be your protege and i really
think i can be the next uh magnus
yeah yeah he's gotta work with me you
gotta work with me
not not with my advice but uh but
i'm sure yeah all right so he's going
after us
yes i like it i like it so that's why
we're gonna
we're gonna go night we're gonna go
night
okay
all right um you said never go backwards
right
uh yo okay maybe this is one of the
cases
okay
no no you pick you pick any any night
move is fine
with any night like there are there are
more more nights
okay um i
think this is wow i have been logged off
automatically for inactivity okay come
on
seriously but that's fine i'm pretty
sure i can
yeah for inactivity come on
all right so he uh we're probably gonna
see g5
next from him yeah right yep but it's
fine yeah
all right let's see how do we how do we
deal with this
uh let's let's let's let's let's
not not the greatest but what are you
gonna do
sorry did you want me to move that night
after you said you have two nights i
thought maybe you meant the other night
no no it's fine it's fine it's fine uh
let's go let's go let's go pawn let's go
pawn
okay or otherwise we're going to get too
entangled
it's 10 p.m in finland it's 9 p.m in
croatia
the board is cut off again oh it's
probably
probably because uh chess.com logged me
out for some reason
ah come on man it's not
cool not cool all right
i will fix it no worries
no worries i'm reading the check guys
sorry i'm in the chat
all right over here all right we're back
we're back there we go
all right sorry it's taking a while all
right so he captured with the knight now
we go
now we go uh now we go pawn
yeah we go pawn i think that's
perfectly reasonable
not that pawn no
no it's a it's a good pawn it's a good
part
are we not not that pawn
any pawn is fine any point is fine
no no it's not a game between me and
niles
niles and i are in a hand and brain
clash against the
chess champ champ all right he played
rogue g1
interesting uh i'm still gonna go pawn
i'm killing you with these pawn moves
huh yeah
there's a lot to think about yeah
okay
and also uh midnight lion walk is an
absolute masterpiece says jp lancer
thank you man
oh yeah i i really don't know which pawn
you want
i think i'm gonna go that pawn
oh that's that's the one that i wanted
it indeed it's the one you wanted to
begin with
yep but you weren't worried about check
on h7
nah but the knight is covering h7 oh
yeah but even if he wasn't it'd also be
fine
so now now he's worried now we are going
at him
yeah he's getting a little bit trapped
there with his knight
yeah especially when you hear what my
next move is
it's probably going to be pawn yeah i'm
guessing it would be fine
well yeah e5 is done with one idea in
mind right
so all right
we still have to you know get some
development in but
uh yeah oh oh
that's i thought about i thought he
might do that
yeah we're still gonna we're still gonna
play pawn
he's not scaring us okay
okay all right now
what's what's his nasty plan
that g6 square is weak but
i don't see a good way for him to take
advantage of that
like i see no way for him to take
advantage of that
so i think we're good here if we don't
lose on time i think we're actually good
here
oh yeah could be the first game that
we're good here
all right okay we might even
we might even win on time ourselves okay
the pawn is coming
all right now you have to concentrate
a lot for this next move okay okay
because it's uh well
i don't want to spoil too much but it's
it's actually pawn
okay this is this is the good stuff
kind of was thinking about the other
pawn but
we'll make this work we'll make this
work well i just want
i wanted his queen not to get in the mix
that was okay
okay okay all right so we
we were expecting this and we don't mind
this so
we're gonna go night okay
yeah this is the bar opening library
variation a very very nicely put froggy
woggy
all right let me make sure i'm not
rushing into this
we're gonna go tonight okay
um
[Music]
i believe that's what you want me to do
almost i kind of wanted you to capture
the pawn with
the other knight but
we will make this work we'll make this
work oh my god that was so stupid
oh my god oh man
no this will this will confuse him
completely
[Laughter]
oh man dude i'm playing some of the
worst chess right now
it's so much to focus on with this
streaming [ __ ] going on
yeah you think it's uh easy to play
chess and stream that's the
you know it it's twice as difficult at
least
uh i hate myself i'm playing such bad
chess
right now that's fine all right so
now now is the moment of of truth
uh i i would say night but you're gonna
ruin our position if i say knight
yeah so so i'm gonna say bishop
i'm gonna say bishop and hope for the
best
okay god i'm gonna let you down
i'm sorry no no no it's it's we we got
this
this is completely fine
all right all right
all right
uh that's fine i i would have gone one
square further
just to prevent him from castling uh but
this is
uh also good uh we're gonna make use of
that pawn of his and g6 that pawn of
his and g6 will uh will be our shield
for the rest of the game
okay oh i got us into a mess
all right so now he he kind of escaped
but we're gonna go after him so pawn
okay yeah
time is not our friend
okay upon um just he takes if i do that
so
okay that's that's the stuff that's the
stuff
oh my god we're down to 20 seconds yeah
next move next next move you can play
pawn
whatever he plays unless unless i say
otherwise
yeah pawn pawn
and now all right first i want to see if
he attacks our queen
if he doesn't we're fine
okay queen
okay i guess we'll we will have to make
do
all right and rook now let's let's go
rook
okay um
all right next move pre-move pawn
pre-move pawn
we might be able to do it
dude i don't have pre-move turned on or
something it didn't work
oh really oh you have to turn it on
uh yeah i
actually i i actually don't know
i don't want leeches when you try and
pre-move and it's not turned on it uh
asks you do you wanna maybe turn turn it
on right
all right so yeah this is this is bad
all right no it was it was a good one if
we had a few more
a few more seconds and we had him easy
you think so yeah i mean he was down to
like his last health bar
i love your positivity i'm starting to
realize it's complete [ __ ] but
no no no uh this was uh i mean
uh few few moves a bit more
you know aggressive and that's it you
you're you're holding back a bit too
much
okay you're always uh afraid to go
forward
uh but okay we can yeah okay uh
we had a lot of challenges in the chat
do you want to play someone from the
chat
yeah let's do it uh i don't know puzzles
is also fun to do together i don't know
but
i've never tried them here but how do
you even do them together
actually i i'm not totally sure oh wow
so
he made a big mistake with e2 and then i
probably okay
i'm sorry i'm just analyzing it now okay
i don't know
okay i'm not seeing your analysis i
guess uh i think you would just have to
see it on my stream
yeah but okay
wha what was the end position like maybe
plus seven for him
okay uh the end position let me see
i'm guessing
like maybe not who knows
cronaldinha says plus 77.
okay so i guess i guess there was a
seven
wait it liked black better here
nah am i crazy nah no way
i mean i could check yo i'm telling you
it liked black better here
oh yeah it did wow interesting yeah
yeah so what what is it that i didn't
see
or or maybe we didn't see i mean
after king b1 well uh i guess
i guess we can check yeah so okay so
basically
yeah just just doubling up on the c file
with the rook seems to be enough i i
don't know
i mean that that is the plan but i just
uh presume the white has like
everything figured out on the queen side
and that white is faster but obviously
not
so also the engine the engine isn't
considering that i'm going to be playing
the rest of the moves
yeah but uh but uh you see
we we got a winning position so that's
yeah that's
that's the stuff but i do think that
maybe that's
too little time for like the chatting
and everything else going on
okay i mean you want to go you want to
go higher let's do
let's do more yeah you'll pick the or
maybe
maybe maybe the same time format but
with a little bit of increment i don't
know maybe you'd prefer that
increment could help uh all
the requests i'm getting for 10 minutes
yeah i'm just going to go to the
bathroom real quick i'll be right back
all right i'm going to now i'm going to
read my chat for a little bit because
i wasn't able to do that as you guys
whoa i just knocked something over it's
my joypad the one i used to play zelda
with
all right so that's that's the stuff
[Music]
i should teach him some openings nah if
he if he was interested in learning
openings he'd learn openings
uh but uh okay i might show him like the
evans gambit that's a that's a pretty
good one
uh okay i'm gonna i'm gonna uh you can't
challenge me because i'm only
uh saying the moves niles is actually
playing them
is now streaming from the bar uh could
be yeah
uh but uh you guys can follow uh
what's his name niall niles dar on
chess.com and you can challenge him
and uh you can play a game against us
something uh his camera went off a
little bit
but i guess that's because he went to
the bathroom
he didn't want to you know uh harass us
with that
epiphan doing great man doing great yeah
i'm here
or a gag on the board yeah i know my
camera is inverted i just
uh thought i'd try it like this to see
if
if it's like super super disturbing
are you back man
[Music]
i'm not seeing you on camera
oh sorry
maybe it can unplug oh oh wow
i don't know
sleeping behind me uh you can actually
see him like
if i maybe rotate a little bit that's
like half of meadow
okay i think you're almost coming back
i'm almost
back sorry yeah it's like it's like the
camera is staring in the
you know into the abyss
one second one second
yeah it defaulted to my regular camera
which is being hidden
by the by the good camera so
now it's just staring so here i am
that's me
okay there we go and maybe i'll just
stick with that i don't know because now
that
now i'm not sure the other camera is uh
here let me it's pretty much the same
like are they the same cameras
yeah that's like the same it's like
marginally better
and definitely more expensive yeah
all right i think everything is working
now
okay cool uh so whenever you're ready
let's
let's win one okay let me uh add my
microphone i'm not sure if my microphone
is working
um
yeah you can switch the cameras and zoom
yeah i've seen
yeah i've seen i've seen on instagram
some i
won the the comedian's tournament some
somebody wins every tournament isn't
some i like the the strongest of them
yeah he actually went to school and and
he kind of trained for it
for the tournament yeah no i mean no he
trains in general i think
oh yeah
can you guys hear me
ah they came yeah if you're wondering
why uh
is asking can you hear him because he's
streaming on twitch uh
so he's checking if the other stream is
working properly as well
yeah let's see
check check check okay now seems to be
working
i think on my way to the bathroom i
unplugged everything i like
ripped it out somehow yeah that happens
all right i think we're back um
okay cool uh all right let's
maybe maybe i i think but i think like
we played
this 10 minute game so well i think if
we did another 10 minutes that we would
be unstoppable but if you want to go 15
we can do 15
okay i'll do 10 with increment okay
what's wrong with that no no it's fine
i don't think we played it that well
yeah i i didn't play it that well
you were playing it oh my god they just
they come so fast
i can't even click on one of these
things yeah but it's it's much easier
for me because i just say pawn
and you know one one of the pawn moves
is
probably probably good and then if you
want
do you want me to be the uh the brain
you be the hand
no no i actually i enjoy it this way
yeah because you don't have to be
embarrassed uh
oh i saw one i just saw one uh i i i'm
pretty sure someone from my chat
challenged you like maybe a few people
okay so i don't accept any of those
i just got one and uh we're playing with
the white pieces let me know if you see
my screen
no uh but probably because i'm again not
following you so i have to go
here um no i have to go play
live chess and then here right follow
yeah like this all right there we go
all right so we're gonna go super
aggressive and so let's go pawn yeah
okay
super aggressive all right let's go
let's go night
okay
nibbles is asking what would you say to
aspiring producers
as a tip or as advice
but first spawn okay
[Music]
um okay first pawn
um
i don't know i feel like from my opening
experience
if i do this and then take with night it
starts to get annoying
but here i'll just
okay i'll just go aggressive like that
yeah that's the stuff yeah i don't know
for some reason the screen just uh
readjusted itself uh every game uh let's
go
uh all right we are playing in the style
of morphe
so uh we're gonna gonna go bishop
yeah all right
okay uh bishop
um did magnus retire so so i've heard
someone made a video about it i'm a
little bit
worried if i do okay there's like some
tactics you could do
there but okay uh
just bishop huh you think white bishop
or
i know i i i can't say i can't say
that's not how
in the brain that's not allowed okay
that's exactly what i wanted
that is exactly what i wanted
yeah he uh i've heard magnus is focusing
on tetris now someone someone made a
video about that
i don't know some weirdo
dude was that one of the biggest uh the
biggest videos you made was the
april fool's what do you mean in terms
of views
or like in the short in a short amount
of time like getting a lot of views in a
short time
uh okay maybe maybe not uh i don't know
like for the first day yes but uh
i i think the video on the on the
queen's gambit
like got more throughout the week that
was like that was perfect
uh all right so he's uh preparing some
nasty stuff
uh let's go all right let's see if he's
uh
if he's present in the game let's go
night
okay
you were just waiting waiting to grab
that pawn
no i mean the pawn was gonna fall
uh have i seen tal versus bobot yeah i i
even made a video on that
like maybe three or four years ago
all right so obviously we're gonna go
bishop
okay
this is one of those positions where any
move with the bishop is fine
uh okay next move pre-move knight
or rather don't no no let's not do that
no let's do it let's do it
yeah am i am i tripping right now is any
kind of caught
yeah he's not doing all that great does
it does he have a tactic here or are we
just about to win a piece
um no he doesn't have
much no okay
i'm guessing i i i cannot say anything
i'm only the
the brain
all right but we're still down on time
we can't get anywhere time-wise
but it's fine i'm a little surprised you
said knight
uh in that position well i didn't want
you to capture the pawn
i actually was thinking about knight g5
just for fun
but you are you are too positional you
always go for the for the correct moves
you need to stop being so nice man
i'm not going to get better oh wow
that's uh
that's interesting to say the least yeah
uh wow that's uh it's actually not bad
it's actually not bad
all right i don't wanna no i don't want
the rook i'm not very
interested in the rook
yeah but there but there's nothing
better
[Music]
well all right let's go let's go queen
okay let's go queen for fun
okay
i was i was afraid you were gonna go
queen to h5 that that wouldn't be
too too great but we did it
all right nothing nothing can stop us
now
okay i think so i think we've got i
think we've got a good position
how's the chat doing i didn't get to say
hi to enough
people on the chat
all right so he he definitely found a
refutation for our idea
all right can we can we make this
interesting
or or can't we
hmm yeah
yeah we're going to have to we're going
to have to take it i mean if we
if i try to complicate it we might get
uh
tangled so let's go let's go bishop
let's go bishop
okay knight c6 is nothing
knight c6 is nothing
this is fine and we don't have to worry
about anything for for the rest of the
game
i love this confidence yeah
you weren't wrong with your confidence
in the last game the engine actually
liked us
it had us yeah i knew we
we were we were onto something
definitely
okay uh
[Music]
this is now very interesting
this is very interesting
all right well i mean we're definitely
going to do the do
queen i think maybe maybe there was some
some sorcery here but no so we'll do
i'm thinking queen c3
okay you can't tell me i know but
i like queen c3 i think okay
uh if he captures the knight obviously
queen yeah
if he doesn't then we'll we'll see what
happens
oh i should have oh no i'm okay here
bishop protects upon another one yeah
that'd be that'd be too much if he had
that
yeah no i think this is one game that we
cannot lose and now we are probably
going to lose it
and now that you say that yeah yeah
who is speaking russian in the
background no one's speaking russian
okay he missed
that uh that bishop was covering this
square unfortunately
he wasn't watching the stream yeah so i
guess we're gonna go bishop
okay oh that was very unfortunate for
him
good night you guys good night matash
going to sleep
all right
okay i think this is a queen move uh
okay let me check yeah it's definitely a
queen move
okay someone is asking what
uh what software do you use for your
music
i use ableton i make music with ableton
yeah even even i know what that is
wow okay have you ever done anything
with music
no but i've been to a lot of parties and
uh
some of my friends were also into djing
and then
everyone was well uh that was a lot of
years ago but i think uh appleton was
just
starting up and it was like super
expensive and you had to have like
uh very good equipment for it and uh
not a lot of people could afford it
could afford dj equipment or or ableton
because april 10 isn't
isn't very expensive like you can get a
basic version for not very much
ah okay i don't know it was a quite
quite a long time ago
but what's not a lot
hundred bucks or something 200 yeah
all right so he's going he's going for
for us
all right um
okay let's make it interesting and go
king
okay i think we can't go wrong here
that that's the stuff so yeah that's the
stuff yeah
you just want to be showy you want to
show off and do a
no it's it's a it's not it's not even a
sacrifice i mean
so no no i mean it's a it's a it's a
poor yeah
but it's if anything we're we're just
developing quickly and there's not much
he can do like
if he moves the bishop we can even you
know
do whatever we want the rook is coming
into the game this is
this is one game we're doing well
good finally i'm glad that i didn't let
uh
didn't let my hero down my idol
oh there's there's still time there's
still time
yeah okay but even if we lose on time
it's okay
uh like last game we had uh we had a
we had a monster position but we lost
some time
unfortunately clearly winning position
yeah this is growing position even
though we had no idea it was that good
but
you know we played well i hadn't i
hadn't
turned the engine on yet yeah i was
waiting yeah i wish and i'd start using
the engine
all right now now let's trick him
completely oh but i don't want to trick
you as well
so let's go let's go bishop
this is a very sneaky one yeah
i see it
all right now now all the lines are open
ableton has more plugins than uh fl
studio
you know to be honest they're all good
programs
yeah it comes you know it comes down to
the producer people always ask me that
like what it which dog
uh you know the the software we use is
called the daw d-a-w
and uh to be honest they're all
they're all good at this point like
there was a time when some were better
than others but
at this point they're all good they're
all um yeah they're
wrong all right so he's giving up
material but
we don't wanna we don't want material we
wanna
[Music]
play in great style so we're gonna go
we're gonna go rook
okay
all right let's see how much how much
damage we can do with the rook
you're enjoying this now
you're a bit of a bully huh okay we need
one
one bad move all right it's not a
not the greatest but uh if he moved the
king we had mate in one
uh yes oh i see
we we don't want to overthink this
all right what's what's interesting here
he's actually managed to bring his
knight into a position that protects the
bishop
nah it's not really that knight is not
protecting you oh it's pinned it's
pinned
yeah yeah i'm just checking if
okay uh i mean
is i don't want to grab material
you could take with the rook there's
probably a line that works
oh yeah okay let's go rook i don't know
i don't know no no
rook let's go you're the brain really go
right yeah
okay
[Laughter]
geez now i'm gonna regret saying that
honestly
no no no there's checkmate yeah
yeah yeah
perhaps i mean i don't know
no we can still we can still lose on
time
yeah we can still lose something
all right so how do we how do we do this
hmm he's probably not gonna capture it
no because he's realizing that because
we took it it was not a good idea yeah
so he might yeah it doesn't matter what
he does like yeah he doesn't have a good
move here
yeah so i'm guessing
whatever he does you pre you you
pre-move queen there are
three queen moves possible that depend
on what he does
how does that work like you do their
move and then you do their
your move if they do that yeah that's
how you preview that okay
i'm guessing i don't know
i don't want to mess it up this is this
is the first game i would have ever
pre-moved anything in my life
no no don't pre-move anything because
there are
multiple uh possibilities here
will is asking will
you make a music production course
yeah actually so if you go to my website
which is dharma
worldwide.com uh you can see
all of my lessons and i've done so many
actually i go from like the beginning of
music production to
more more advanced stuff there's just
about everything is on the site
a dharma worldwide yeah i know
i remember oh he actually blocked with
the bishop
yeah okay now he's just uh i mean
now we can do pretty much anything so
so so so or rather no
super super fun
okay
huh there is a move
it's a tactic kind of thing i feel like
bishop
g5 is like a tactic bishop g5
okay yeah i mean i of course yeah and
queen captures like what bishop d7 and
you win the queen
yeah but but i don't know if there's a
checkmate checkmate's better of course
yeah we could have captured the queen a
long time ago if you wanted to
so oh man
you tell me
i think it's time for a quiet move
okay it's time for a quiet move and
that's rook
yeah yeah rook
as a quiet move yeah
now we could take the pawn with the
queen but i mean then he
he grabs the bishop and what it's
nothing nothing is really happening
okay so rook has a quiet move
yeah um okay i
i i'm thinking e4
but god i don't want to mess it up
okay i think this is what you mean so
yeah not now we're good now we're good
okay
he's really he's really making us work
for our meal
yeah he is
somebody said i can't see your video it
gets stuck i don't know
no i think this one's perfectly fine
no uh people are saying that the video
got stuck i
mean i'm still not good at this
no no i know it doesn't lose a bishop i
i but
there there isn't a forced mate or
anything so there's no
queen d6 is always an option that it's
not disappearing
yeah no no there are plenty of moves
that win
i was just trying to find the most
aesthetically pleasing way to win this
not just to win it
oh my friend dr luke just uh he just
texted me he's watching the chess
channel doctor looks like one of the
biggest producers of all time
and he's watching he loves chess he's
watching right now what doctor do
duke dr luke hello
yeah dr lou he's he did everything from
britney spears to katy perry he's like
absolute mega producer
yeah he plays chess
uh yeah he i he plays chess yeah
have you watched me have you played
against him no i don't think i ever
played against him
all right so now now the fun starts
uh we we knew that he was gonna go for
that rook move
obviously okay uh but we don't
we don't really mind so i'm guessing
yeah okay i mean okay let's go let's go
bishop otherwise
we're gonna lose too much time okay
um
[Music]
yeah that's the stuff and now he's down
to down to 20 seconds
and that's it so he's gonna trade off
now i'm assuming to deal with some of
the threats
yeah uh there's nothing to trade down
okay so now we don't have to take that
we can just go bishop
and that's it you just go
bishop that's it yeah um
[Music]
the board messed up again come on yeah
that's the stuff that's the bishop
all right uh just have to fix my board
for some reason the board keeps getting
messed up
sorry i'm not uh uh yeah obviously rook
yeah
all right let me just fix that you know
constantly fixing things i mean this is
how do i do this all right we fixed it
man all right so now
now we don't really care uh yeah let's
play queen
you could have even captured the rook i
was gonna okay can we pick up the rook
for a moment no we have to play knight
we don't want to blunder the bishop
okay yeah this is a special board with
no h file yeah
okay the board is fully operational now
um yeah i mean anything night
night where night wherever just pick it
up and wherever it falls that's fine
there we go
okay queen maybe mikasa eckerman
donated 100 and says uh
i'm just gonna do queen uh
yeah we have time i mean no it's okay
yeah do queen do queen
very nice all right
let's go let's do knight
mikasa says it's great to see you
playing chess especially with so little
time on the clock
all right we're gonna go pawn so you
don't have to worry about that knight
constantly being attacked okay
let's go pawn uh yeah
all right so now we play queen
alright king
oh do we play with increment
i think oh okay okay and now queen okay
we have to be careful not to stalemate
him you know all right let's
let's do let's do uh let's do queen
okay
[Music]
oh so you want to torture him okay
sorry let's go let's go queen again
queen again
okay so we don't mess it up
sorry oh oh i see sorry i didn't
maybe he repeats maybe he repeats
all right and now queen
okay let me make sure that is there a
checkmate here
okay oh i can't really say oh
not there no oh god i'm sorry
queen again queen again all right i
gotta see where's the damn checkmate no
queen uh
i'm not seeing the damn checkmate i'm
sorry it's fine
you have 10 seconds it's fine i'm sorry
i just don't see it
ah it's fine
whatever he plays queen we play queen
okay i don't understand how to block off
a4
and yeah yeah well queen c2 blocks a4
yeah
uh all right let's go bishop let's go
bishop we have five seconds
bishop bishop bishop bishop all right
next we pre-move queen
anywhere let's go queen
uh okay um [ __ ]
dude i don't know it's okay next move
rook rook rook rook
wait we have a queen checkmate okay then
then we play queen i guess
okay all right yeah it's fine because uh
you already missed that one
yeah but now but now in in the last move
you play the move that
i didn't recommend oh man
but yeah sorry that was so stressful
dude yeah but
okay it was it was the one that we
already we already mentioned so i guess
it's uh it's fine
but okay i think we're getting much
better yeah
yeah we're getting better for sure yeah
but if we played if we played without
increment he would have lost a long time
ago you know
because he was so low on time yeah all
right let's
do you like or you can't see the
analysis if i analyze right uh
maybe i can okay try uh go uh start up
the analysis board and i'm gonna
no no no yeah i can't i can't you can't
see yeah
but we don't have to analyze it i mean
it's blitz
who analyzes blitz
only only crazy people okay i see a
i see a 10 with a five increment should
i do that
uh yeah i mean it's a bit um a bit much
but
i i think we can do it i think we're for
you maybe man
for you uh okay edward ashes
is it from edward ashes you want me to
do yeah i'll do edward ashes
no he says in the chat that he sent 15
plus 10.
yeah i'll do i'll i'll do it and then
all right let's see oh
my screen's gotten a little bit off now
hold on let me fix it
no i think it's it's fine nothing is uh
i think nothing is
okay i'm just gonna move something so it
doesn't log me out for inactivity
it's like netflix you know probably yeah
yeah
yes come on man i'm watching i mean
okay all right whenever you whenever
you're ready
okay all right i think it i think it's
in the screen somewhere
um all right so he played
e5
oh you're already playing yeah
okay yeah for some reason it's uh again
not
following you i mean it's really weird
it's fine
i'm gonna get there no problem okay
we're gonna
like this thanks to the chat i know how
to do this
uh all right uh
yeah i mean obviously pawn and now the
board again gets messed up
i have no idea why the interface is
doing this but yeah
pawn obviously and just another pawn
yeah yeah okay you know kings gambit and
stuff
okay
all right let's let's keep it like this
that was a little aggressive but
all right let's go pawn
okay
okay very nice very nice
board cut off at the worst time yeah
uh let's go let's go
bishop okay
yeah i know you like the bishop c4 move
so that's why
i always say go for the bishop
all right edward ashes let's see if we
can take out edward
i got medora dr luke says he would like
some lessons from you
no problem no problem i'm introducing
you to the producer world now
yeah we have to you know spread those
chess roots worldwide
i think it's a good crossover a lot of
nerds in the producer world
yeah i i i would imagine as much
after meeting me right now no no no
nerds in chess what's whatsoever
okay so he's gone for night season
yeah we we go night yeah night okay
okay
all right so i think uh whatever he
plays
we probably go yeah we go king
okay
hey the nerd gamer is here
uh let's do very interesting let's do
pawn let's do pawn okay
okay just start a little complex there
is that what we want
someone says dr luke made every hit in
2012.
do we uh let's see i don't know which
pawn you want
um anyone if i didn't think any pawn was
good i would never say pawn
i always say pawn when every pawn move
is good
okay feels like a weird position but
uh yeah no it's fine how is he going to
castle i mean look at this this is
we just have to play we just have to
play very aggressive and you know
uh scare him a little bit all right
this is a this is a fine moment and
uh we are going to play
bishop now
you know think think think like morphy
okay i'm gonna play bishop
um
[Music]
think like morphe um like just
take like just be aggressive and take
yeah i i cannot say but
you're not opposed to that no no never
i'm never opposed to
today okay here we say capturing
yeah okay this is aggressive but all
right that's the stuff yes that's the
stuff
since our pawn is already on e5 so we
want to take advantage of that all right
now we go
knight now we go knight
this is this is far from good but we we
will try
is this what you wanted yeah and now we
go
pawn now we go pawn
now we go pawn yeah
okay that's the stuff yeah that's the
stuff
you you've guessed every move this is
incredible really
okay yeah
all right now we can basically do
anything we want
so how do we make most of it
yeah okay obviously we there's no need
to rush anything there's no need to rush
okay let's try and let's try and nice
night would be the first level right
like that's the most
yeah but yeah but there's no stopping
that so maybe
there's no need to rush this
let's go super aggressive and go go pawn
okay pawn pawn uh
pon pon pon go super aggressive pawn
uh i don't know i guess i'm assuming if
you're saying aggressive you mean like
that
yeah let's go with that that's perfectly
fine okay
let's let's go
[Laughter]
is that what you meant uh yeah
yeah but yeah about f5 i thought maybe
f5 or maybe g4 then f5
something okay now pawn
now pawn yeah
what pawn
okay
that's the stuff yeah let's win back our
piece
we can always play knight f7 and we we
really don't want that room wow that was
an easy tactic i can't believe i didn't
see that
yeah because that uh we're not ex we're
we're gonna try and finish the game
before that
rook ever enters the game so we don't
want to give up our night for rook
if we can avoid it for the moment
all right that's that's the good stuff
it's not going to be easy
what do you mean it's not going to be
easy for
for him oh for him yeah
all right oh that's nice that's nice
that's actually nice okay there is no
rush there is no rush
there's no rush
if we had more pawns that'd be great but
we don't
so hmm
how do we get this guy a bit more active
yeah we really are in no rush let's go
yeah let's go night let's go night
just to force the situation or to get
more pieces in there
you don't want to rush no no there are
there are more nights
there isn't just one night i know this
now
okay um
so he
i'm worried about losing our
fun with the with the fork but you're
not worried about losing the fork
okay no the the there is no possible
fork
what do you mean wait knight to f7 is
possible for it
ah no no i thought you meant his fork
yeah okay no
you're not worried about us losing that
board no no i'm not interested in the
rook
okay i i prefer my knight there
if he wants to chase it away okay then
maybe he can force that
yeah okay uh we're just trying to
get a few more attackers into the game
if possible
all right very interesting
very interesting
all right so this is not
not bad not bad
all right we're gonna go yeah we're
gonna go night
definitely go night oh sorry pawn i met
pawn
i meant pawn
all right let's see what he does let's
see what he does
i think yeah okay i i i i'm pretty sure
we
pre-move night uh yeah go
go with the knight okay
it's fine i i i wanted to get the other
knight into the game
but that's fine
but i felt like oh after he takes with
the bishop it's
really no problem okay so he
he's uh not interested in taking that
right away
um okay let's go night
let's go night okay
plenty of time
many producers like chess everyone likes
chess man
uh okay what did he just play
oh nothing still all right nothing yeah
you're
playing movie you're looking for oh
that's always the night move i'm looking
for
yeah i mean we're just gonna
if he doesn't okay he grabbed with the
queen that's
very interesting okay
well definitely night
like i'm pretty sure in this position
any move with any knight
is fine okay
all right playing in in great style i
like it i like it thank you thank you
wow there's so many so many good moves
here it's
it's impossible to pick one
okay this is this is the good stuff
okay so he's is he trying something
sneaky not really he's trying to get
sneaky
he's trying to get sneaky yeah let's go
okay let's not uh
do anything weird let's just go uh
let's go bishop
okay put some put some pressure
[Music]
okay
yeah one good bishop move so
that's that's the good stuff yeah so
we don't we we're without a worry in the
world really
i like it when you talk like that no
this is such a
fine position
this makes me happy this is how every
game should be
yeah we we yeah i mean
when you when you wanted to take with
the bishop i wonder if there was a way
to defend
uh when we did the sacrifice in the
beginning um
yeah of course of course it's uh i mean
mostly for fun but if he gives us a move
or two for free
all right now now the you know the the
worlds are oyster
as they say yeah
all right so now i guess we we can do
anything
let's go
wow so many so many great options
not even not even kidding all right
let's go
okay if i do this then you're probably
going to do that
this is intuitive for me okay okay okay
then go bishop
if if you prefer bishop go bishop
okay um the
night i just wouldn't be totally sure
how do you oh no i guess i can see okay
i yeah i'm comfortable with this other
song yeah whatever whatever you prefer
all right things are getting really
really serious now
yeah he can pick up whatever he wants
yeah all right he doesn't even want to
capture that he
he's on to us all right now
i guess it's time to bring more more of
our forces into the attack
so let's go let's go queen
okay
there's too much too much stuff to
capture
all right now queen again
it's a very very very good pawn i like
that
all right
uh there's probably a better move well
no actually all right let's let's see
what do we do now this just seems
reported
oh actually no no no no we we have to we
have to do queen we have to do queen we
have to do queen for
optimal performance
we have to do plane yeah okay and then
we're doing great
do you want to exchange you can't tell
me um
do you like your queen i i'm really
never
down for exchanging
you're never down for exchanging nah
i prefer to keep all the pieces on the
board
always okay
wow this is this is a really nasty
position
but that's what that's what we wanted i
mean
okay
all the way back okay all the way back
it's uh maybe a bit risky but uh yeah
oh maybe i should have you know what
maybe i should have traded we're giving
up these things now there aren't we
no no okay oh this is a this is a fine
move
uh you know uh so i i call mate in one
but you know you're you have to find it
did he make a move yeah he played bishop
b7
oh my thinking is frozen or something
really no not now
uh no it's okay it's not frozen um
he he really could have uh you know
had us worried here but
there's a mate and one here oh there
could be yes
he's threatening the main one yes but so
are you
no he's actually not threatening mate at
all
oh yeah we have mate we have made
we have if we have then let's go for it
if such a move exists
there we go nice nice i think i think
uh i think edward maybe allowed us
too much here but yeah i think i was
blundering a little bit at the end there
no but it was a you know you you found
all the correct pawn moves like you just
went forward it was a
very very very aggressive style i i
i really like that all right so
one more one more and we're we're good
eh
yeah i think honestly my brain is kind
of fried and i i think i have to get to
work now i have to get some music work
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah you you also had
the vaccine
so you know probably a few days for it
to wear off
yeah i've got to recover um but anyway
man this was awesome i got to meet
one of my idols uh somebody that i've
been a really big fan
of for a long time so this is an awesome
experience for me
do you even you know manage the time for
for some chess
uh honestly i mostly played puzzles uh
puzzles yeah like fundamental right
times
like puzzle rush yeah or the rated one
so you're just
getting your rating up for puzzles up
and up and up i'm almost at 2000 i'm at
like 1900
or something ah yeah that's where those
uh pawn pushes came from yeah
i i guess so man but i'm i'm definitely
gonna look back and
and analyze these uh analyze these games
for sure
yeah yeah okay there
i mean there's not there's always more
to be done but
uh it's the most important uh thing is
to have fun
so i i think we we we got that part
correctly
yeah for sure man i'd i'd love to do it
again sometime we should we should
sure thing all right thank you niles and
thank you guys
until next time man and everybody watch
the world we left behind video it's out
uh it's out right now it just came out
so all right i'll check it out
i'm gonna share it in the in the in the
chat right now
okay awesome yeah i'll i'll share it
here and
just to make sure you have the right
link i'm gonna give you
this one uh where are you sharing it
too uh in your whatsapp i shared it
oh okay nice nice nice yeah there we go
yeah thanks so much
thanks so much for doing this with me
man it was really fun yeah did we even
lose a game i think we lost maybe like
one like yeah yeah we resigned one and
then time trouble on one
but um basically the undefeated
basically
yeah yeah it was a perfect streak almost
yeah
yeah okay let me get better all right
man i'll see you brother
until next time all right until next
time
peace
all right guys uh that's it for this one
i was uh
merely a short stream to to introduce
niles to you guys a bit and to
promote his new song so do check it out
i just posted it in the
in the comments uh and i i hear there's
a a lot of content currently happening
uh
online so do do enjoy that so uh we'll
see you guys uh
guys tomorrow probably not probably
definitely
see you soon